hey everyone
welcome back to another video by simply
learn
this video on react.js helps you build
two fun applications
using the library as you all know react
is a widely used javascript library
to build user interfaces for
applications
this video will make you realize why it
is adopted so widely so first
we'll build a calculator app and then
we'll move on to building a spotify
clone
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
now i'm sure you're excited to build
these apps so let's begin
this time we're going to introduce you
another very interesting project using
this javascript html
css so called calculator application
so let's get started let me try to
delete first those files which we really
do not need it now
we delete this all yeah now i will be
creating a new folder now
and give the name called
calculator app and in this calculator
app once again we need some new files
which is called index
dot html and
we also need one more that is called
app.css
and another one that is app dot js
so these three files required now first
of all i would start with
index.html file where we'll be creating
a template of my code
now let me go and create this template
and here i have a god body with me
let's start with the first
tag here that is called h1 and this h1
we are giving the name called
calculator
calculator app so that will be my h1
heading
after that we'll start working with the
div tag
now within this div i would have to
create lot many classes
i may not have lot many css classes but
we can
give some classes here so we can say
class equal to
container okay so within this div tag
we're going to create a table now
because i want to organize it
so i'm starting with the table within
this table
tr tag and within this tr tag i need a
td
now in this td i need few things call
call
span equal to 3 another value
and here i want to offer the text box
input type equal to
text okay input up to text
id equal to give the name called result
that will be the final outcome while
pressing all the different buttons id
equal to result and
class equal to
screen remember i haven't created those
css classes
but but we're giving some names but
later on we can utilize it
while creating those css classes table
data is getting closed
let's get started with another td now
insert this td
we need another text box
input type equal to
text and here in this input
text sorry i would like to better say
button because i'll be having
buttons
okay input i'm equal to
button value
equal to c
and on click equal to
i may not have any function right now
but yes i can create
a function but let me give some domain
name here
i'm saying clear screen
okay so that will be the function will
get called and after that
class equal to
clear yeah
so this is my button tag
after this the td tag is getting closed
after the td tag
the table row is also getting closed
after the table row
which is getting close we're going to
start working with another table row
okay and in this table row i'm going to
create
one more td so let's go ahead and create
another td here and inside this td
i'll be having another projector we get
created
so i'll just say
this is my another button now input
button value equal to
one or click equal to i'll be calling
another function
called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
value call one
okay and class equal to member
plus equal to number and here after the
tettering tag is getting closed
okay now you have to start another td
tag here
okay like that we have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data now here
again value equal to 2 on click product
display
give the value call 2 and class equal to
what
number like that i'll keep on creating
multiple buttons but first check
how it actually looks like
now i can see the buttons like in c one
two three
but yes i'm gonna create few more
buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here and create
few more buttons so this is where the
table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this and paste it again
how to create the button
like in 3 4 something like that
so after this two we're giving the value
called three
here i'll give the value call three
so val equal to two well equal to three
display three
and then afterwards just giving the
value call
forward slash and here also we're gonna
keep the value from
forward slash and here class equal to
operator
operator after that you have to do the
value call
4 and then followed by 567
so here we give 4.
four five
five six
six after six we're giving call minus
[Music]
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
operator okay after this
minus we'll be talking about call 7
then we have to have 8.
okay nine
okay after that we're giving for plus
and display plus
plus equal to operator
operator okay so here
you can see the table data is getting
closed
and here the table is also getting
closed and after this table row we can
start working with
another table here
and after this table row
we can start working with again td let
me have this
again
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is value equal to
dot and here we get the value called
decimal
okay now display zero
so after giving this dot basically take
what
the value zero which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have another one
zero zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that we'll be once again
taking this and this time rather than
giving this
zero we'll be using this call as a
button
and value equal to equal
or click equal to
solve okay and then this soft will not
be passing anything
it like a normal function and plus equal
to
equal
okay so table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only okay
we will be using well equal to
multiplication
display
plastic and here we'll be using operator
okay so table data is getting close
table room is getting close table is
also getting closed here
okay so your dev tag is also getting
closed here
okay that's it okay so
that's the only thing which we wanted to
make let me try to refresh and check
awesome so we have got all those
necessary calculator behavior which uh
we wanted to reveal
okay now our next statement will be once
we're giving this c then we have a call
of one two three
and then forward slash followed by four
five six
will come down
okay so let me check whether we have
used six or not
okay so we haven't used six so let me
check here
four five six so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later on
before minus
six equal to number
okay so we're almost set now so we are
having this
uh look and feel in this way giving one
two three four five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then
plus related behavior so we are all set
now and after that we'll be basically
applying
the css as well as the javascript look
towards my code
okay thank you well everybody we are all
good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my uh
this outlook is looking properly or not
see what my expectation is after one two
three forward slash
i really want to bring 456 to the next
and then seven eight nine and again
forward still but i can think this is
absolutely
unorganized so after this when we say
this uh forward slash which we have used
after hyphen
okay your tt is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start
another tr here
okay so that i can put them into the
another level now
so under this tr i can use this td now
so after this minus
after four five six minus once again i
would like to start
another table over here okay so that it
let's go to the next row
so here after td
we're closing this dr and starting
another tier
okay we're starting another tier after
that we talk about 789
okay plus
see here talking about 789 plus here the
table
is getting close and it is starting
right now like this
see that looks better now okay
but still few more things which i would
like to make it even more organized
but that's not a problem we will do it
later on
okay because you can see eight is
missing right now so
here seven we copy this
equal to eight
eight yeah that looks better now so
now they are basically completely
organized so the moment
i expect my application so we have a
call
dot here then zero then equal to and
then multiplication
okay so it looks better now now i just
would like to perform
the overall look and feel so i need to
go ahead and use what css
because without css i really can't
utilize this in a proper way
so i have to start working with a css
friend now
in css front how to start first we will
go back to my code
and here in my css we will start working
with
font family but before font fabric i
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color i'm using
that looks nice okay so
i will be using this app.css in my html
to see the look how it is been appeared
right now
so in my index.html file on the top
under my head section
link
start sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward in my css
we want to use some h1 correct tool
so here we would like to use the h1
text align center
color
white margin top
margin top we'd like to use 50 pixels
this is for h1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement will be called screen so
we say
dot
screen so in this screen we use the
background color
sorry
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white font size
medium
next width
we're using this 100
then we talk about cursor
what are the default cursor is
okay then padding we would like to say
10 pixels
and then margin
save auto then
margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay look
that's how exactly we want that's for
the screen where the
exact outcome will be visible to me and
rest of the details we'll be showing you
one by one
and now we'll be talking about call
input
okay input
type equal to button
for input type equal to button
okay input of type
over the overrun button i say
background color change to what
right or else i can say
let's walk
okay and when the button is active
what i want let me copy
like this you can see now how it is
basically looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about color
operators operator should behave
different so i'm saying dot
operator in this operator we are saying
background color
background color orange
okay that paddy
want five pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using call border
sorry
that border i'm using this called solid
and then black and
then height
height is 40 pixels
then cursor
it has to be pointed okay
that's it let's check
perfect so they shall turn back to what
to your orange color and
you can see the moment you take macros
on the returns to white perfect
and now those were type number i also
want to change them
so for number
for number i want to save the same
option
padding i want 5 pixels
then i need height of type 40 pixels
then i say color it looks
i want to say called black then
border
border i want solid
black into excess solid
black two pixels
then width i would say point width 700
let's check awesome so they looks nice
now we're left few other type of
options like in dot and equal to okay
that i'm talking about called decimal
decimal i need to have a different
options with me okay
so let me try to copy this
paste it and i say for
does it so for decimal background color
will be
light blue padding five pixels color
black border solid
okay black two pixels with hundred
percent height forty pixels five
cursor pointer perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color to light blue
now i talk about
clear okay now come back
and say clear
okay in this color background color is
i'm changed to
light salmon
light salmon padding 5 pixels color
black
border height 40 pixels
fine so cursor pointer
file margin
auto and margin bottom
merging bottom differences
let's check perfect
not looks beautiful okay
now here after giving these details
we're talking about call equal part dot
equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so we recall background color adding
color
just change to
light green
light green and
after this since it is a equal so we say
padding five pixels
is okay color black fine border fine
with hundred percent high 40 pixels
color and cursor pointers just i don't
need to
it's for dot equal and i want for
container
container in this container width i want
40 percent
red 40 percent background color white
okay now here
writing is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all you call width you see
display block which we're taking
margin
okay in margin basic pixels
auto
okay now align cells
go to center
okay border radius
border radius let's just say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
box shadow 5 pixels
and padding
so these are details okay
we have it background color we are
taking it now
align cell display block border radius
padding
and then writing 15 pixels we've given
audi
i don't need to give it again okay
fine box shadow let's try
awesome so it's looking beautiful now
okay
so this is where exactly my application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
100
okay that's it
super so it's now giving me the proper
look of how
my application should be here i can just
see about the container what we have
done
with 40 we are taking background color
let's bring it below then align cell
display block okay margin
okay and border radius
and uh fine so i think we're all good
now
so that's it so we'll try and implement
the javascript part
well everyone so our css file is ready
our html is ready it's time to just
go ahead and talk about my final
question that is called gs part where i
want to basically perform some
calculators
now here i just say function display
function display which takes val as in
parameter
and say document dot
get element by id here i'm saying
result okay dot
value
okay plus equal to
whatever we are adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay there is a function after that we
have another functions available here
called
function solved here in the solve
we just use the value called let x equal
to
document dot get element by id
result
okay dot value
sorry dot
value okay and say
let y equal to
perform the calculations for the will be
using one function called
eval and type axis and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document.
get it runway id
result dot
value equal to y
okay now later on
i'll write to use another function here
function
clear screen
and here we say document.
get it in my id here we say
result dot
value equal to like that
so clear screen solve
and display three functions are
associated
with me and these three functions are
the part of this javascript file which
i'll be calling it
at the end before the water tag get
closed so here
that's it okay let's try to execute now
here two you can see the values
i will say plus six
equal to eight absolutely i say c is
clear the screen
six divided by 2
equal to 3 awesome so friends
your calculator application is ready
congratulations to all
so it is a very simplest form which we
have developed this is your html
which is a template for you this is the
css which is your complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like in
of this template beautification
and here last year for js which is
smaller logic but really meaningful
okay if getting your learning started is
half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
let's start with creating a simple demo
on react.js and we are going to create a
simple
application that will connect to an
online
music streaming service called spotify
and we will call our application
music app so let's get started the first
step
is to first get the node.js platform
and server installed to do that let me
go to google
and let's just type node.js and here is
the website nodejs.org there are two
versions available
the lts which is the stable version and
the current
we'll prefer the stable so we'll click
on that and
you can see we have an option which is
called save file the moment this file is
saved to the disk we just need to double
click on it
and keep clicking on the next button to
get it installed
on our system and we also have a
documentation
available here so which explains most of
the features
of the node platform and there are
binaries available for different os's
mac windows etc so you can select
the right witness 32-bit 64-bit and the
right os
and then go ahead and download the
specific
version that suits your platform
and you can see here that there are
different
there are also help files available that
will allow you to go through the
installation documents for node.js
installation on linux etc so to start
with uh
i'm opening up the command prompt and
here is where
we're going to call the node package
manager using
the node package manager which is
pre-installed with your standard
installation we will initialize our
react application
so we would say react dash app and
we want to now go and create an
application called
music app in this folder so as a
prerequisite for the demo
all we need to do is install node.js
from node.js.org the official website
just download it
and install it and that's when you open
the command prompt you fire
npm which stands for node package
manager init for initialize
react dash app is a standard keyword to
initialize and create a skeletal
structure of a react.js application
and the name of the app is music app so
we'll hit enter
we'll give this some time and you can
see it's
started downloading the core react.js
libraries
and it is attempting to create our
application
so it's installing all the prerequisite
packages and scripts that are required
initialize and create a new react.js
application called
music app now once this application is
created
all we would require is an online editor
so you could use an offline or an
on-premise editor as well so any editor
of your choice
it could be atom or sublime text or
webstorm
and for this demo we're going to use
visual studio code which is a free
editor
available by microsoft and you can just
google for visual studio code
again uh this is not visual studio
professional edition etc that we use for
building our c-sharp or mbc-based
applications this is a lightweight
editor for building javascript based
footstep
full applications so so while this
installs let's go and take a look at
uh visual studio code so this is the
visual studio code
editor and this is the editor that we've
installed directly downloaded from
visualstudiocode.com and
installed it and all we need to do is
open up this
folder that would be created with all
the prerequisite files in it
we just say file open folder and we
would open that folder
within our visual studio code editor so
we'll give it a while
until that application gets generated
and once it's created
we will again implement the component
based design and architecture
and the data flow between the components
and we'll also look at connecting to a
live data source
which is a json set of characters that
we would consume which is a restful
service
the set of music tracks exposed as a
restful api
endpoint by spotify which is a premium
streaming service
we will connect to that and we will look
at accessing some of the music tracks on
that website
okay so we've got uh the application
created here
so let's minimize this and we'll open up
our editor
all we've got to say is file and open
folder
and let me go to the react.js demo
folder so this is the music app
that got created and that's exactly what
we're going to open up here
so we'll navigate to that folder
it's called music app we'll select it
and
have it opened in our application so you
can see here we've got a note modules
folder this has all of the pre-installed
packages that
make up the react.js library we've got a
folder called
public which will have the index.html
file that's the root
file that will launch so this is the
single page
application that we typically create in
a react
you have a single page which on which
we're going to load multiple components
so that's the index.html and then we
could go and create
a folder structure currently if i open
the source folder
we can see a single app.js file and that
basically is
the file that has uh the source code in
javascript for a single component
which we are interested in adding on to
our page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding css file
and then we've got the a public folder
with
the index.html file which is going to be
the root html file that launches
when we run our application so let's
uh go right up here and let's add
a link to an additional file so i'm
going to link to another style sheet
okay so we'd say relationship is equal
to stylesheet
and the type is going to be text
and css and we will reference
a file called reset
dot css and this is a file that we
look at adding up later on it doesn't
exist at this point in time
so we will connect this and that's
purely for styling purposes
so that we can have all of our css
styles defined there
next thing i'll right click on the
public folder we'll create a new file
we'll name this file as reset dot
css so that's going to be the css file
that will have
all of the css uh styling that we're
going to apply
and i'm going to use a ready code
snippet
uh for the css code so let me just
uh okay so i'll all i'll do is i'll just
go and pick up
a ready css file that i can just go and
use
if you look here i have a set of css
files that are created that
we're just going to use within our
application
and and that will avoid us spending a
lot of time on the styling so that we
can focus on our core concepts
uh which is actually learning how
component based architecture works and
how do we set up components
and have data communication between them
in react so uh
here is a file called uh reset.css
let me just fire up notepad and i'll
just open up this file
copy up the text here and i'm going to
just paste it
within my reset.css and if you look at
the code uh
very simple it's all about styling so
we've got uh
article aside etc all html5 tags set up
as display block so they take up the
entire width of the page
we've got some padding margin and font
size etc defined
we've removed list styling for the
unordered and ordered list
specifying the line height for the body
tag so basically uh
just styling up tables and so nothing
nothing to do with react here it's just
about simple
uh css that we've added up uh and now we
need to actually go in and dive into
create creation of the components that
we need
so let's right click on the source
folder so i'll select the source folder
we'll right click there
and that's where we're going to create a
new folder which is called
components okay so this is the
components folder now that's going to
hold
all of the components within it within
the components folder let me create
another new folder and i'm going to call
it app and this is exactly how
we are expected to structure all of the
code that we have
now i already have a css and app.js
which are the root components that were
added by default
and all i'm going to do is i'm going to
move them
within this folder called app okay so
there's a proper segregation of
responsibility
and all of the code that deals with a
particular component
is all added into respective folders and
this really improves the maintainability
of the application
uh going forward now we need some images
and i'm just going to make use of some
set of images that i've downloaded from
the web
and here are the set of images that i
have
so i'm just going to copy all of them
and we'll come to
our music app and we'll go into the
components and app folder
and that's where we're going to add all
of the files and you've seen
all of those image files getting added
so these are just icons and images we're
going to use for our music tracks
inside our application now let's move to
the app.css file
and this is where we've actually got
uh so the app.css file is
the file that's going to style up the
all of the style rules that we've added
into the root app component
and this is what we'll have to revamp so
i'll just get rid of this code
and we'll probably add something for the
body tag
the html tag and the root element
let me say hash root and let's set
the height to a hundred percent coming
to
all of the html across the page we'll
give it a font size
of 10 pixels and the
h1 elements let me give it a padding of
0.77 and 0
let's set a background color
give it a background color and just
select
some random color here that can be
applied then
we'll set up the text alignment which is
going to be the center of the page
we'll set up the font family the font
family
is and this is part of
sans serif what else do we add let's add
up the font size
1.88 and also the color
so again uh these are standard uh html
and css
elements so uh nothing really that has
to be done
that is specific to react here so again
we are bringing in the highlight class
so there is
a class called highlight that we will
create later in the uh
html view of this component and we will
set this to
a red rgb component so combination of 46
113 and 238
okay so that's uh pretty much done let's
move on and also add up for the anchor
tag
let's add up some text decoration and
set it to none so that the anchor tags
don't come up with those
underlines and of course we'll provide a
color of hash
okay so a white color there now coming
to the h2 element
for the h2 element let's have font
family and again i'm going to use
so i'm going to use the font family that
we defined
here bracket and we change this to
probably 1.55
okay now coming to the app tag uh let me
just
save this and create a copy of it uh
there was some content
that i did delete and
i can simply go and make use of it so
i've just
undone all of the deletion so this is
uh something that i can't uh if i can
use something i can just probably
use it from the tag below so let me
start with the height here
and let's say the height of the header
is hundred percent of the app sorry not
header
padding 0 17
10 17 the background
and i'm going to change that to
background url so the background url
or let's say the background image will
have a url property okay and that url
is going to be dot slash pg1 dot
jpeg so that's the image that we've
added some
in the previous step let's also add
background size so we'll add background
size and set it to cover
i also need a background position
set it to center let's have background
repeat
which is set to no repeat so that we
don't have the image
in a grid format uh and then
i would need this a bit of it let's take
up the font family we'll maintain the
same font family
let's use font weight the font weight
is going to be 500 and the color is
going to be
hash so that's a white color then we
come to
dot app dot playlist so that's going to
be
another class that we are going to use
dot but
app dash playlist is what we we're going
to name it
and let me say that the display
should be flex flexible display
and we will justify the content
to leave spaces in between all right so
that
finishes that bit and now uh
let's write up a media query for the
responsiveness of this
page so this is
media for only screen and
max width is going to be one zero two
zero pixels
okay and the class name that we'll
provide later
is obviously app playlist so for this
screen
size we would align all the items
to the center and we change the flex
direction
okay so we seem to be good with the css
for the app as of now and that's the
app.css
that we created let me save everything
okay let's check uh for any kind of
uh additional so all three of errors
no errors now things are good in the app
css and it's time to move to the next
step
of building this application uh now we
have to go
and add up the code for
the app.js file so let's dive into the
app.js file
and this is where we will actually need
to go
and add all of the code that is required
for
the app component so all the code that's
relevant to
the app component we are going to add up
inside this
specific component itself which is going
to be obviously the
app.js file so we have skeletal code
which is import
importing the react library and let me
get rid of the
basic sample logo we'll have app.css
that's getting imported here
besides that lot of other files that
we'll have to get in so
let me import playlist and this is these
are the components that we'll create
as we go forward and we're going to get
this
from the playlist folder and the
component
the file is going to be called playlist
so we'll add that
then we'll have to go and also import
search bar
so what we're basically doing is we're
going to split this app
into different components there's going
to be one component that manages uh the
playlist
of all the tracks one component will
act as the search bar so that's the
search bar
component that we're going to add so
searching for tracks will be managed by
this we'll have another component that
we'll create
that will get imported into the root app
component which is a
search results so this is going to
display the record set
with the set of results as an outcome of
the search criteria
so search results slash search
results and finally we'll go and import
spotify that's the spotify service from
so we'll create a utility folder which
will hold
the code that connects us to spotify so
that's what we are adding up next so all
of the imports are done
one component that manages the search
bar so that search bar
search results let me correct the
spellings there that search results that
spotify
and playlist so that's done now let's
move on to
the class that we're going to create
here so let's create
a class app that goes and extends
dot component so that's going to be a
react.js component
so that's a constructor we discussed
about props
or properties and state management and
that's what we are implementing
we are using the super keyword as a best
practice
so that all the properties are
initialized in the constructor
and also we pass the values
up the chain to the superclass which is
the root component class
now we're going to initialize a variable
called state that's going to manage
the state and we are interested in
tracking our search results so we'll
have multiple results so we'll store
that as an array the playlist
would have different names so we'll just
call
ours new playlist that's the default
name
and we will also store a list of
tracks which is going to be playlist
tracks
so playlist tracks is going to be a list
of tracks and
let's close this block okay and this two
is going to be initialized within the
constructor so we'll add it here
and now we need to do the binding we
discussed uh
data binding so let's look at creating a
search
variable which will hold this dot
search dot bind and bind to the context
of
this very class so we are passing this
pointer then
we'll create another variable called add
track which to this dot add track
dot bind and all this functionality is
what we're going to add going forward so
right now
we're just setting up the bindings then
we'll have
capability to remove a track so we'll
say remove
track so remove track equal to this
dot remove track dot pint
and let's fix that
so and all of this too is going to be
initialized as
part of the constructor so that's where
we're going to add it
then we'll need to update update the
playlist name
so we need functionality that will help
us to update
the name of the playlist so
functionality that helps us to update
the playlist name so this dot update
playlist
name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind
and this is the pointer that we'll pass
i need to save the playlist so this dot
save playlist equal to this dot
save playlist dot find and pass
this and then i would also need to
remove
the track that has been searched for
from the playlist
so remove track search go to this
dot okay remove track search and
dot find and finally one last function
that executes all of these
which probably will bind to bind to this
context so all the declarations
are done in the constructor now we need
to provide
the definitions for all the methods that
we actually have
added here so let me select this tab
inside and let's start
with the search function so we define
the search first
it takes some variable value that it
searches on and
then i'm going to say spotify dot
search i'm going to search for term dot
then and that's an observable so
the moment it the search returns a value
it's going to call this
uh callback function and that's when we
want to set
the state and we're going to set the
state
for search results to whatever is passed
by the system so the search results are
going to be returned
as a callback and that's what we store
as an updated state
now coming to the add track method so
let's scroll up and we'll say
add track and this will take the track
to be added
let's declare a temporary variable
called tracks equal to this dot
the current state of all the tracks that
are there
in the playlist now if tracks
dot find i'm going to call the find
method
so if we are able to find which means
that the track is already there in the
playlist
then we would not want to add it if it's
not there
in the playlist that's when we would
want to go and
it the triple equal to is an equality
operator that will check for both
a watch value match and a match on the
data type
as well okay so if the track is uh
already saved to nothing if the track is
not safe just track the
track id because that is the track that
will uh
have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks
we'll use the javascript method called
push and we will push the current track
into this tracks array and then update
the state
so we want to set the state of the
playlist
tracks and this is how uh your state
management that we discussed
in detail is actually being practically
implemented here
okay so the track has been added now
let's talk about the remove track
so that's the remove track function and
that's
the track that we want to remove so
let's
let tracks equal to this dot state
dot playlist tracks those the set of
current tracks that we have
and let track search another temporary
variable
equal to this dot the current state of
the search results
then let's take the tracks array equal
to
track start filter so filter is of
javascript function that will again
allow you to remove
a certain value create a temporary
variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id
is not equal to the track dot
id which means this particular track is
not there in the list okay so you need
to
remove that and again i have a method
called as
unshift which will actually get rid of
the track
in the array and then we've got to so
we'll search
whether that track is existing in the
tracks
array if it is then we simply want to
remove it if not we do nothing
so we set the state we need to update
the state of the playlist because the
track has been removed
so the playlist tracks will have to be
updated with this
tracks array okay then we go for remove
track search that's the next method that
also will take
a track as a parameter okay here we are
going to say let
tracks which is another temporary
variable we'll give it this current
state
of search results and then we're going
to say tracks
equal to tracks dot filter
current track current track dot id
not be equal to the track dot id and
then
this is where we would want to say this
dot
set state and we'll pick up search
results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh
set of tracks after making that change
let's
remove this and correct it okay so
that's fine
so the remove track is now the remove
track in the remove track search is now
in place
let's add the do these functions which
actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say
this dot add track okay so it adds the
track
and then it removes the track from
the search criteria so the search
component which is managing searching of
the tracks it will go and remove it from
there after adding the new track
so that's a combined operation we want
to
execute then i've got update playlist
name which will take the name of the
track to update and this dot
set state the playlist name is what we
need to update with the name that is
passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists
so here we let me create a constant
variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change
we'll take all the track uris dot
state dot playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track
track dot url so we actually want to go
and uh now save this on
a spotify so that's the reason we'll
access
spotify's safe playlist method this
dot state dot playlist
name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into
a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function
where we're going to say this dot set
date
and the playlist name that we want to
create
on spotify will be called new playlist
so that's the custom name that i want to
provide
and the playlist tracks define
that this closes here okay so that's for
the update on
spotify now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript
and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your
html view and synchronize and bind the
data
together so it helps from a
maintainability perspective
so even though everything is in the same
file it's well
classified and differentiated into
different code blocks
so we'll add the anchor tag and we'd say
href
is http localhost so that's the default
server port on which this application
will run
okay and we want to give it a custom url
name of musical file
so the h1 terminates will then say div
class name equal to app within that
this is how we're going to inject a
search bar
that's going to be the search bar
component
injected here and on search so that's
the custom event
we will call a method called search so
on search
we just call we bind to a method called
this dot search then we'll open up
another div
here we'll have class name equal to app
dash playlist and if you remember that's
exactly the css
class name that we refer to in the css
file we have another component called
search
results that we're going to inject here
and that's going to be search results
here search results will be equal to
this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be
displayed with the data bound and if
somebody says add if
if i click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist
by calling binding to the duties
function and it will remove it from the
search results text box then we have
another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks will be
bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor then we provided the
function definitions
okay that's how and this that we passed
refers to the
context of the current component itself
so whatever you put into the app
component or into the respective
component those values will be then
passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things
we'll have to do is if somebody changes
the name of the track so on name change
is going to be another custom event
where we have to call this
dot update playlist name and we also
have remove functionality so to remove a
track
we would say equal to this dot remove
track
on save equal to this dot save
playlist okay so that's done and we
close this
so we seem to be pretty much on track
the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components
it's very similar to the public access
specifiers etc that you provide
uh in other programming languages so
that's done
we've created our app component now
let's create
another folder under components and
we've got to define
all our various components here this
folder is
going to be for the search bar so we'll
name it search bar
we'll add two files within it the search
bar dot css okay and
another file that we'll need here is
search bar dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file
so we'll start with first styling search
bar we will say that the display
should be flex flex direction
should be column we want all the items
to be
aligned at the center so that's align
item center
then we'll add up padding so padding top
is going to be 6.94
rpm and margin
bottom is going to be 6.33
rem all right now let's add up
for the search bar so that's search bar
we'll add for the input element we want
the width
to be 287 pixels the padding
to be zero point eight eight
zero the border should be one pixel
solid white the border radius will give
a slight
rounded edge uh to give a web 3.0 look
and feel so we'll set up the border
radius
then we've got margin bottom
so we've got a bottom margin that we
want to add up
then we have color so let's add up the
color
c3f so that's the color black then let's
add
text alignment of center and
let's add up a font size of one rem okay
so that's how we've
set this up let's add the search
bar input is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks
inside so the end user goes and clicks
inside the text box so
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
uh
on input and if the input is focused so
that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search
button so on the search button the
cursor
will set it to pointer so that's the
cursor pointer
the width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and 0
the border radius we'll set it to 54
pixels so we get a slightly
uh well-defined search button with a
nice little border
let's also add background color hash
one db nine five four
that gives me a color then i've got my
text alignment
let's set that to center then we've got
uh a font family let's set up the font
family to the same standard font
a t and it's a part of
the sans serif family then we'll set up
the font size to 0.833
rem correct this and finally
we will need transition so all of these
are
basic css properties so that will
add a slight transitional effect with a
delay of
that many milliseconds so transition
background color we've provided what
else let me scroll up
let's also provide a border here so
we'll remove
in fact let's remove the border we we
would not want a border on the button
that would look
odd so i'll get rid of the border and
color we'll specify
as per our standard color that we've
been using okay so that's the color
we've
specified and then i've got font weight
of 500. finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button
we will register for the over event so
if someone takes
their mouse over the button that's the
hover
event in that case uh if we hover around
the button we would want
the background color to change so it
will
appear to have a slight little glow
there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes
the css file
for the search bar and we obviously now
need to go and get the code in
for our search bar component and that's
exactly
what we are going to do next so let's
start with
setting up the code for the search bar
first thing
let's go and import react from
react next thing we would want to do is
import the search bar dot
css file then we define a class
called search bar which extends
react dot component we define
our constructor and we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we'll just need one variable
here which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and then
let's say this dot will define a
function called
handle term change which is going to be
equal to this dot handle handle term
change dot find so that's going to be
the first function
then a function that will do the
searching for us
which is this dot search so that's the
search function
and we'll have it bind to this then
we've got
this dot handle enter
so the moment we enter into that search
text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is
handle term change we'll pass it a
system defined keyword of event
this dot set state and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get
the value that is there inside
that text box the moment the search term
the user is entered
changes so the search criteria changes
we trap the updated value
then in the search function we will
update
the local property props dot on
search okay so we'll access the on
search and pass it the updated
term and then we got the handle enter
on which uh we're also going to pass the
system define
event keyword so if there's any data
flowing along with the event
we are interested in it in this case the
data is the key code that the user is
pressing and if it is 13 that indicates
that's the ascii key code for the enter
button so if the enter is hit then the
user is completed
entering the search criteria and we need
to start searching and that's where
we write our render method that's going
to render the html view
and we return the complete view here so
that's the view now that we want to
return
let's say tiff class name equal to
search bar
then on the input text box we will use
placeholder equal to enter song
album or artist that you want to
search for on change on the on change
event
the moment the term changes we connect
that to
handle term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on
key up is where we would want to connect
to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i have to put up here
so in the render function
uh we're going to return a value i
shouldn't forget to export the search
bar okay so that's
uh what i want to export so we've
exported that
okay so at the end of this uh what we've
done is we've written a render method
we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close the div
tag
we've added an input and here is where
i'm going to add a button provide a
class name called search button
and the moment the end user clicks on
the button
we're going to connect it to this dot
search
and we close the button tag within the
button tag
search so that completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's
run through all of what we've written we
started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor
passing props to the super class
constructor
we created state we set it to
a value of term and null so the state
currently we defined as term then we
said handle term changes search and
handle enter should be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter
we've also defined then we used render
render we said is going to return to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the
html that we want this component to
return to us
so on change and on key up are
two functions that or two events that we
connected to
where we called handle term change and
handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event
and connected it to this dot search so
all the three functions
uh that we are actually written
uh so two things we've completed now uh
in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc
adding tracks removing tracks
then we've created the search bar
okay so we saw that the search bar also
we have specified a set of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care
to structure every component separately
so the search component is doing
something completely different
which is managing the search bar we have
the core the root
app component in which we have imported
all of the other
set of javascript classes that we are
creating
and that's how the entire application
is now structured so and that's the core
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have
every separate block of code or every
separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether
so we've completed the search bar
component as well
so two components done and two
components uh
good to go so we've got to start up on
the next set of components that we will
need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder
a new file called track.css
and track.js
so that's going to manage the tracks for
us
so let's start with dot track
we would say display is flex
align items center border
bottom 1 pixel solid rgba
256 256
256 0.8 that's the opacity
then let's come to track action
so we'll use all of these classes uh
when we write up
the html view we'll add a padding here
of 0.5
we'll set up a font size of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.25
s order of 0 pixel
and a background color of rgb
a 0 0 0 0 color hash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in
track another class track action and
if we hover over this class we want
the gb values change to 265
265 2 6 5 5 is the last paragraph so
that's the hover
then we have track information so track
information
is the next class that we're dealing
with we'll add
the flex parameter first display
flex and then flex
direction is going to be column
let's have justify content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's a track
information let's have another track
information
and the h3 tags nested inside that
for all the h3 tags nested inside that
we'll need a margin
bottom of 0.22
rem finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size of 0.83
rem and a font
weight of 300 and
a color as well that we'll add so let's
add up
a color here rgba 2 6
256 256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's
uh that's in terms of the css and
let's move to the track and
we'll move into the javascript file
so let's move into so let me take what
we added in the search bar
i'll go to the track.js
this will change to track.css
okay the constructor this will change
to add track so add track
change this to add track this is
remove track change this to remove
track get rid of this and that's going
to be
the add track function and here we are
going to say
uh this dot props so we'll modify
this this dot props
dot on add this dot
props dot track and then we have
the remove track so that's going to be
the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot prop start
on remove and this is the track
that we would want to go and remove
we'll add up another function
called uh render action so this is going
to be a function
uh that we are defining called render
action and
in this we'll just check if this dot
props
dot is remove if this dot
props dot is removal
so in that case we would want to return
so this is a view action method that we
are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as
track action that we've already written
the css for
and this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is what it's going to
map to let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function
so that's uh the closing button tag okay
so the closing button tag
is what we've added there and
the binding is what we have done to this
dot remove track and
we will terminate this here so now the
render action
uh let's also have the return
here and we just add up
the button and this is going to
add track so you can look at how the
component is completely dynamic
in nature so we have two buttons that
are going to be added
this button with the hyphen is going to
remove the track this button
uh with the plus sign is going to add
the track
and you can actually see how simply it
was done
in a render action function so the
render action function actually helped
with checking that if
on the value of the props and if the
user
uh depending on the action performed
you will actually be able to remove a
track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
uh
the class name here is now going to be
track
the class name for uh the enclosing div
inside it so let me get rid of this
the class name for the enclosing div
here
is going to be track dash
information within it we'll add h3
we'll bind to this dot props
dot track dot name so the name of the
track
is going to get bound here then in the
paragraph
we will find to this dot props dot
track dot artist and
with some gap this dot props dot
track dot algo so that's what
we've data bound to and then let me add
an iframe an iframe allows us to
very easily inject some content into the
page within a small
embedded window the source parameter of
the frame
is going to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash embed
slash track and close this so that's the
spotify
stream that we are going to connect to
and this dot
props dot track dot id
so that's the track id the width
is going to be 300 the height parameter
this the height parameter is going to be
80
of the iframe and the frame
border is going to be zero and
the allow transparency so that's the
opacity
we'll say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here
and we can also have the title
set to preview so that's uh with the
iframe
okay at the bottom is where we would
want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it right
around here
so we wouldn't need this part and then
here i'm just going to say
this dot render action so we call the
render action method
uh which will actually give us plus
minus button
to add and remove uh new element
okay and that's uh what we can actually
go and add up there
so let's check now whether
all that we've done is good to go fine
so everything looks good
uh in terms of the track component now
and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump
into the next component that we would
require
after the track component and that's
going to be
the track list so this is going to be a
list
component that will comprise of a list
of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this
track list and that's going to have
track list css and it's going to have
track list dot js so that's the
track component now which
we're going to go ahead and use and the
css
we don't need much so let's just say
track
list and we just provide a width
of 100 okay that's all we'll need
uh in the css so let me add this
in the css file save this and come to
the
js file now which is going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react from react
we'd also want to import track list
dot css and
we also want to go and get track
because this component is going to be
made up of a
collection of tracks individual tracks
so we want to get this from
track slash track and we'll define class
track list which is going to go and
extend
react dot component we just need the
render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself
it simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks so this class name
is going to be track list
and we'll find to this dot props dot
tracks dot map create a temporary
variable
and this will go and return
the track component which is going to
bind to
individual track data the key is going
to be track dot
id so the key is going to be
track dot id and on add
on adding a new track we want to bind to
this dot properties dot and we already
have on add
defined so that's what we connect to we
add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need is
removal equal to this
dot props dot is removal
and the on remove will do
this dot prop start on remove
so that's for the track removal and
so we've got our track list
uh oh yes we'll have to go and also
close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export so we'll
have to go
and export the track list
so we've got one more component done
which is track list
and let's move on to the next component
now
so we've got app which is root we've got
the search bar that takes care of uh
entering the search criteria we've got
individual tracks that are searched and
returned and we've got a track list that
manages a set of
track records so the track is more
relevant to the playlist and then we've
got the search results also to manage
once we search for some
set of tracks so we'll add a new folder
which manages
search results and this is going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have search results
dot js okay so we need a search results
dot css and js and here in the css file
we'll keep it
simple for the search results so we say
search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent
we set up the height of 950
pixels we'll say overflow
y is scroll we'll say
padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
95 23 23
0.7 and we will use the box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of
zero for pixels to pixels
to pixels ash and then
uh let's add a scroll bar
so webkit and mozart
are the constants specific to mozilla
and
chrome browsers so they target certain
animated features etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with one zero two zero pixels in that
case
dot search results
width is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of 2
okay so we're going to add hyphen so
it's hyphen webkit
scroll bar zero pixel width
and we've set transparent background so
that's that's about it with
the css i need to get to the uh
js file now let's move to the search
results
js file and that's where we will now
have to go
and add up the component code
for search results and let me
take pick this up from track list
add it up here this would be search
results and we need the results will
return to us
a list of tracks so we'll have to get uh
track
list this will be track list
and i'm just going to return class name
will also be search results so that's
the
component and this is going to
export out search results so it's
accessible across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create tracked list with a
set of tracks
and we will bind it to this dot props
dot search results and on the on add
we're going to bind to this dot
props dot on add so we already have that
so that basically completes search
results
and that leaves us with the last
component which is going to manage
the playlist for us so we'll add up a
new books we'll add up a new folder
in components and that's going to be
playlist and within that we will have
a playlist dot css and
a playlist dot js so that's our
playlist component now that we're going
to work with
and the playlist component is
uh we'll first set up the css that we
will need
to add up to the playlist and i'm just
going to
pick that up from my code snippet
so that's my playlist and let me
get all of that css here so that's
uh just this css for the playlist
nothing to do with react again pure css
let me get into the js file and
that's where we will need to go and add
all of our component code
so again let me go to the track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it out here we'll make some
small changes
this is going to be playlist i need to
import
the track list because the playlist is
going to contain
a list of tracks this is going to be
playlist and let
me here this will be playlist
and we'll leave this for later okay
let me also get the constructor in
so we'll add up the constructor here and
just one function that we will need here
which is handle name change you know if
i need to change the name of the
playlist
so handle name change and that's exactly
the function
that we will need to write code for so
that's the event
and this dot props dot
on name change that's when we'll say
event
dot target dot value so we get the
updated playlist
name coming to the render we now need
the input input is going to be
on change equal to this dot
handle name change the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is
new playlist so that's the default value
if not provided then we'll just pick up
the default value
then we've got track list so track list
is what i will add the tracks i'm going
to bind to
this dot props dot playlist
tracks so we're going to bind this to
playlist
tracks and here we will say
is removal equal to
true and on remove equal to we'll bind
that to this dot props
dot on remove finally we'll need a
button
we will use class name equal to
playlist dash save
that's what we've added in the css click
equal to
this dot props dot on
save and here we're going to say save
to spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export
playlist and not track list
now we'll need to do a quick look up
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in and create an
id it takes us to our dashboard
that's where we can create a sample
application
the name of the application will be
musical
file okay and we'll say that we are
building
uh some kind of desktop app for example
for which we want to connect this to and
we'll also need to provide
uh so we'll say next refresh the
dashboard
so it's uh asking me for a login so let
me
login once more so moment i login that's
going to be
description and i'll say maybe this is
why i need it
i'll say no not commercial integration
agree with the terms and conditions
and we will say submit and that's the
application that has got created and now
i can say
edit settings and the redirect url here
is what is important so it should accept
connections from http localhost
3000 that's the port on which we will
host our application
okay and we'll say save okay so that's
uh
now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique
so i'll just copy that up let me come up
to my
application under the source folder i'm
going to add
a new folder called util and
under that a new file called spotify.js
so we will start with adding our code to
the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util
folder the first line of code is going
to define
a client id variable that equates to the
client id
that we will generate on spotify so
this is going to be the spotify
generated client id which is a unique id
associated for the developer to connect
to the spotify
api and we will look at the source of
that
as we go through the demo the next
variable that we'll create
is the redirect url or let's call it
redirect uri and that will
equate to localhost colon 3000
which is the port and we'll create
another variable
called the access token let's also
create another constant variable
called spotify and this will work
like a function expression so we'll
equate it
to a function called get access token
and we will say
if access token is true then
return the access token now let's
declare
a constant variable called access token
match
which will be equal to window dot
location dot href dot
match and we will say this is equal to
access token which will be equal to and
we will give a rejects expression
to do a pattern match ampersand so that
we can actually get into the url and
extract
the token information from that and
hence
the pattern match is crucial here
another constant
variable called expires in
match equal to window dot location
dot href dot match here
we will read the expiry information
using another edgex expression from the
url
ampersand asterisk so that's the second
constant variable we've created
now we will say if access token
match and expires in
match in that case the access token
should be equal to access token match
of one then we create a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from
the expires in match that's done
then we will say window.settimeout
and we are going to say access token
equal to comma expires in
multiplied by thousand then we will say
window dot history dot push
state and we will say access token
we pass the second parameter as null the
last parameter
as slash and close this and we will
return
access token else we will say
const access url equal to
https accounts.spotify.com
slash authorize
client underscore id equal to
dollar client id ampersand response
type equal to token ampersand
scope equal to playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now
get generated so we will say modify
dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect
uri so we have constructed the url
now that will go out and get generated
in the browser and here we are going to
say window dot location
equal to access url then
we'll add the search criteria function
which accepts a term
as a parameter to search on here we will
say
constant access token equal to
spotify dot get access token so we get a
reference to the same access token
return we call the fetch function and
we're going to pass
https api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash search question mark that's the
query string that we will add type equal
to track
and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization
where we will say that the pairer is
dollar access token dot then
response return response dot
json dot then so the return of this
function once it completes
we will then call the next function so
json response and then we will say
return response dot json
after that another then block so we'll
now
say json response and if
not jsonresponse.tracks
in that case we will return an
empty array else we will return
json response dot tracks
dot items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as a variable with a
lambda expression
and we'll create a temporary json object
with id
and that's where we want to associate
track dot id
that was returned as the search result
the name
is going to be associated with track dot
name
the artist is going to be associated
with
track dot artists of zero dot
name the album is going to be track
dot album dot name and the uri
we will equate track dot url so that
completes
uh this block will open the next
and we this will be the save playlist
which will take the name and the track
uris
and here we will check if not
name or not track uris dot
len in that case we simply return out of
the code
and then we declare a constant variable
called
access token which will be equal to
spotify
dot get access token so we get a
reference to the access token
we then declare headers authorization
bearer is going to be dollar access
token
and we'll create a user id and now we
will return
the fetch result where we will pass
https
api dot spotify dot com
slash v1 slash me
so that's the url comma headers will be
the
header information then we call the then
function declare response as a variable
use the lambda expression and access
response dot
json we use the then block to declare
json response here we say
user id equal to json response dot id
and then we return fetch https
api dot spotify.com
slash v1 slash users
slash dollar of user id
slash playlist so this is how we've
constructed the urls manually
here we will say assign headers to
the headers variable we'll assign method
as host so the data is sent as part of
the body
and not as part of the url and
as the body we will say json.stringify
to convert this parameter name
and then we will generate a response
variable to response.js
and then we'll create jsonresponse
with the lambda operation we'll create a
constant
playlist id which is equal to
jsonresponse.id we will
return fetch https
api.spotify.com
v1 users dollar
user id slash playlist
slash dollar again we are constructing
the url so playlist id will be replaced
here then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again
we will say headers would equate to the
headers
variable be constant headers
and this goes here
okay everything fixed now so here we are
going to say
headers should equate to headers
and the method is going to be
post and the body
is going to be json dot stringify
uris track uris and we close this
we close this block we close this block
and
we close this block so that completes
our code
of course one more thing we have to do
which is export this class out
so export default spotify
and that completes the code for the
spotify.js
which is part of our utils
class so let's move on now to the next
step
so uh here is uh the client id that
we'll have to exactly match so i'll copy
this client id
and provide it here so that's the client
id uh that we actually need
and we could also store it out here
so that's the client id and that's the
redirect url that we've also
defined there and we just create an
access token
if here the access token is true we
return
access token so the access token is
something that we are going to do a
match from
uh the moment we try and connect
with this particular url and you can
look here that this is the access url
that we are trying to connect with
okay with the client id and post fixed
with
the redirect url right and then i've got
a simple search function
which returns an observable so we try to
fetch data
using the search term that we provided
okay we try to fetch
data using the search term provided if
we are successful we get a response of
the data
and accordingly we'll iterate over the
json response and get a list of tracks
out of it
and do a mapping of this json object to
the track id name
artist information album name etc and
here
just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save
function which will save this data to
spotify as well so i've got a save
playlist
and i've got search so these are the two
functions which
will go and connect to the spotify
service uh by using
this client id and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning
a stream of json data and will then
allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we actually need
to
start up the application so i'll go to
the terminal and
rather let me go to view and bring out
the
terminal so this is the integrated
terminal that's there
in the tool and it just opens powershell
from which you can actually
fire your commands so i'm going to say
node package manager npm
start to actually start up this
application
so that's going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access
so i need to grant access to that port
3000 let's give it time to run
and that's the app now that you can
actually see here
so this is uh the search bar that we
actually had
okay then we had the results we had the
playlist
now the results is going to consist of a
set of
tracks which are maintained by the track
list and then you can take individual
tracks with the plus and minus button
and add them into the playlist
okay so that's how it's typically going
to work
okay so as you can view here i'm just
going to search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually uh
gave us
uh a confirmation link the moment we
tried to connect
and execute our application uh that's
proof enough that it actually went
and connected to the service there
and tried to return a value to us so
this is what we did we just added an
artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons
getting added on the fly so that was the
render action
these are buttons that got added onto
this list of tracks
dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist
okay as in when i click here so i've
added a couple of tracks
if i go back to my dashboard of my music
file
application and that i've created here
in the developers portal of spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank
so now i'm going to click on save to
spotify
okay and that clears the playlist so let
me come
here and now when i come out here
we saw that it actually got successfully
connected
out here now i'll have to log in to so
this was the development app that we
actually created on the developers
portal of spotify
now we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and
it says do you want to launch the web
player and all that so let me click on
that
so it just launches and can you see here
this is the new playlist
that just got added right and there were
four songs that i'd actually added
to the playlist and you can see here
those four songs have got added out here
okay so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it
okay so there's no playlist now i'll go
back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify
so that's how you actually saw that the
new playlist you can see the new
playlist has come back here
okay and that's the playlist uh the
playlist has got generated again and
that's the new playlist
that got created and we deleted it
but it still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity
uh that we successfully created with
this react app and the core concept of
the react app was breaking it down
into components which is the search
component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks
then we created the search results which
will generate a list of results which
further contains
a track list and this is the embedded
iframe which gave us the response
which is scrollable here and you can see
that the iframes we created allowed us
to scroll
this with this embedded web page inside
the iframe container
so with that i hope we've been
successful with explaining the
concept of component based design and
architecture with react and how
important it is to create individual
components and the benefit of that
being that you can isolate change
requests to a certain component you can
promote reusability
wherever you want the same feature to be
implemented on the page you can just
inject that same component and the same
implementation and the same features can
be reused so it promotes reusability it
promotes flexibility to change
it isolates your change request to
single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and retesting the entire
application as a whole and so with that
we come to the end of this session
i hope you enjoyed building these
applications thank you so much for being
here and watch out for more videos from
us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here